j'accueille maintenant enrico macias
paroisse
j'avais un écho très bien avec un
accueil comme sa maman comme chez vos
orientations ricaud vous savez remettez
la sourdine paella tout cas c'est bien
fini pour moi
alors elle un écho bien un loup qu'elle
sera ordinaire c'est vachement bien en
forme ma c'est tout
enrico macias mesdames messieurs 64 ans
alain riffaud when i'm sixty fort 40 ans
de carrière
quarante ans de mariage on va commencer
par la carrière didier j'ai quitté une
amie je vous attends quand c'est dur
en france
c'est là
à 12
devant
plus bas
jallet
le landais combat
j'avais pouvoir nous à paris tu m'as
fait d'enterrer la page
la raison toujours
défaut
bonjour
les gens du nord en dans les îles le
bleu qui manque à leur décor
les gens du nord
en dedans
soleil qui n'ont pas dehors de la marée
noire
moi je
la santé
écoutez de mon banc
et pourtant de la demande
g
pourtant assuré
et à voir avec le coeur qui tambourinent
les oranges amères et l'odeur des
m
comme un cias alors
commerciales et les deux dernières
champions tour
l'entente sont extraits du nouvel album
d'abricots macias qui s'appelle orange
amère
avec le coeur qui tend nourrir à l'égard
je revois
hello there il dort jamais bravo l
alcool est très bonne c'est françois roy
ces mêmes chances complicité félicité
noir casterman
voilà c'est très bonnes chansons et puis
l'autre qu'on a entendu écoute ma voix
c'est kent
voilà alors enrico depuis quelques
années il ya eu l'album hommage consacré
à la musique de cheikh raymond la
musique arabo andalouse à le malouf et
us a ensuite il ya eu un remix de tous
vos grands tubes par bill laswell et là
maintenant avec ce nouveau disque on a
le sentiment d'assister vraiment à un
renouveau à une renaissance d'enrico
macias
je dirais ça un peu comme avec henri
salvador il ya quelques il ya quelques
temps qu'on souhaite faire le même
succès que ouais et salvador ray mais je
dois tout à mon fils qui m'a qui a
réalisé totalement le disque qui m'a
présenté ses nouveaux auteurs ces
nouveaux compositeurs et qui a décidé de
je me suis mis carrément entre ses mains
pendant sept ans j'ai j'ai senti qu'il
fallait que je prenne un peu de recul
qu'il fallait même nous l'a senti alors
je commence ma part
bon
et alors c'est vrai que j'avais
s'étendent rico oui c'est toi les gens
j'avais passé
alors pourquoi pas de chansons nouvelles
pendant sept ans peur de ne pas arriver
à faire des choses qui soit au niveau
des des tubes d'enrico moi j'ai jamais
calculé pour faire des chansons est le
cas ça venait pas ben ça venait pas je
ne pouvais pas forcé je peux pas faut
raser la seulement sur des bases solides
pour faire des suites par exemple les
gens du sud ouest
nantes ap pourtant tu vois tu vois c'est
pas mon style tu vois pour revenir très
fort comme ça j'ai pas besoin de faire
ça mais jean-claude effectivement votre
fils qui vous a convaincu enrico de vous
y remettre
il a réuni une équipe donc à marc estève
alors lui c'est quand même plus facile
parce que son père était footballeur
l'algérino oui oui on a on s'est rappelé
de certains souvenirs
je ne connais pas encore c'est pas vrai
ça va rocker qui vit dans le sud
voilà et qui a fait cette chanson avec
art mengo qui est son grand copain donc
beaucoup de talent qu'on cellule normes
et man 1
c'est vraiment très très belle chanson
est alors quand vous entendez ça arrange
amer oui ces gens tant orange amère et
je me dis là il ya quelque chose de que
je n'ai pas fait encore depuis 40 ans
parce que joueur de refaire la même
chanson est là pour la première fois de
ma vie j'entends quelque chose qui a qui
est dans mon style qui est dans mon
univers musical dans le monde en
environnement et qui rappelle quand même
un grandes chaînes qui rappelle je
m'excuse c'est peut-être grandiloquent
mais c'est pour moi marquer ce thème
c'est un petit peu camus mais dans la
chanson ouais ouais c'est le même style
les choses simples mais autres si
importante quand on se réveille le matin
on demande
il fait beau il fait mauvais il ya du
soleil ça paraît banal mais c'est
vachement important pour murray donc
marc estève art mengo pour cette chanson
orange amère
et puis ensuite jean loup dabadie
georges moustaki et puis quand pour
celle là qui s'appelle écoute ma voix et
de ma voix
pour deux mois
si le pays voici quelque